thank you everyone for coming for this
final day of the data-driven decision
processes bootcamp so
compared to other programs we're going
to do something slightly special today
and instead of going over some new
topics we are going to sort of go over
the legacy of david blackwell but before
i go into this since we are all doing
data driven decision processes uh here's
a data driven decision processes
question for all of y'all so when does
anyone have a prediction
as to when someone will write the last
paper
on these topics on data-driven decision
processes
the last paper
when the world explodes
nobody okay so i'm glad to see nobody's
confident enough to say in a year i'm
working on it
so there actually is
as long as you're frequent as there is a
data driven way of talking about this
it's sometimes called the copenhagen
principle and the idea is
we are not special the field exists and
sometimes we sort of sample it at a
random time so in some sense if you want
to predict when the last paper on this
topic is going to be written
a good predictor is actually looking at
when sort of the first paper on this
topic was written and then basically
multiplying by
like by one over 40 and by 40 to get a
99 confidence interval now i'm sure many
of you
don't completely agree with this that's
because you all are all secretly busy
but you won't admit it
but that sort of raises the question of
when was the first paper in this this
area written this this area that we are
defining in this boot camp and as i
posited to you before i actually think
it's the following so this is a paper
back in 1949
called bayes and minimax solution the
sequential decision making problems
which really completely lays down
exactly all the things that we were
talking about
in a very proto version but at least
like we could have taken that topic and
named our semester after that and none
of you would have blinked
and so sort of going from that it's been
around 80 years since that was written
multiply and divide by 40. the last
paper is going to be written within
either two years or 320 years
[Music]
if it's within two years please credit
the simon's institute for doing work
while you were here
so we're going to celebrate the second
author of this paper but let me sort of
show you a quick
video of the first author of the paper
talking about writing this so this is
canaro
so he said in the year 48 49 um let me
uh try one of the things i worked on in
the summer 48 was with with gershon and
with david blackwell who subsequently
um howard university who subsequently
went to
unfortunately berkeley we try to get him
here for those
[Music]
nice
an outstanding mind
uh so this is ken arrows out of talking
about
one of the other greats in this field
talking about this gentleman david
blackwell and and how in in a talk which
was supposed to be about canaro's life
and the history of stanford he he
couldn't sort of help himself and stop
for a few seconds and just comment upon
how great
this person was uh
and so
that's what we are here to talk about
and and i'm sure many of you must be
asking well okay why
why a whole day dedicated to david
blackwell um and why now
and i'll try to give you three answers
to this question so the first one which
is perhaps the truthful answer is that
we started planning this program so um
along with tadauris de curtis uh
and shipwrecker we started planning this
around 2020 and as we
we were sort of thinking about all the
topics we wanted to cover and then of
course looking at the news and in some
sense in both just in terms of the
intellectual contributions but also in
terms of just the societal impact and
the the role that david blackwell plays
as a role model um we just couldn't help
thinking about him everything everything
we were doing it sort of seemed to tie
back to david blackwell and so when we
finally wrote down the proposal we
decided that a large part of it should
be centered around the legacy of this
gentleman um
but i'm sure many of you will be like
yeah okay that that makes sense uh but
surely there's some special anniversary
or something that this commemorates now
for those of you who are i guess ancient
sumerian or coders or like if you
believe in the hexadecimal system uh it
has been 12 years since
david blackwell left us and so that
seems like a special occasion but
uh
unfortunately unfortunately most of you
are conditioned
by the hindu arabic numerals and so you
would rather find something that this is
the 10th anniversary of uh and it just
so turns out that this is the 10th
anniversary of david blackwell being
awarded the it's the national medal of
science he was awarded at posthumously
in 2012 uh and so before i hand over to
ricky i'm going to show you a quick
video that was produced on the occasion
just to explain the legacy of david
blackwell and in the process of the
video you will see him giving a lecture
i think this is quite long back in the
60s where he's talking about he's
talking about tossing a coin and trying
to predict what are just getting a
sequence of zeros and ones and trying to
predict what the sequence is and he'll
draw this very mysterious looking
diagram where he draws an x and y axis
and he says let's look at the number of
ones and the number of times we've got
it correct and then do this very strange
thing in between
and i'm hoping our next speaker ricky
can illuminate a little bit about what
exactly he's doing there so
let's quickly do
this video and then i'll hand it over to
ricky
what were the odds this illinois child
would become one of the world's great
mathematicians
david blackwell was game to try
i was always pretty good at mathematics
i don't know that i had favorite
subjects i
i studied whatever you were told to
study
did it as well as i could
but i looked forward to recess
[Music]
i was a good student mind you such a
good student that by age 22 he had
earned a phd from the university of
illinois
there's a lot of luck
in things
the man that i chose as my thesis
advisor
was far and away the best possible
choice i could have made
his field probability theory
turned out to have a lot of appeal for
me it turned out that i like to think
that way
blackwell wanted to teach mathematics
and he wanted to serve at historically
black colleges and universities
i got a list of all the black colleges
from some almanac
there were 105 of them i wrote 105
letters i actually accepted the first
offer
that i received as soon as i got it
am really serious mathematical work
started at home
at howard the intellectual atmosphere
was just different
so
every day a machine produces a number
either 0 or 1.
in the mid 50s blackwell joined and soon
after headed the university of
california berkeley's newly created
statistics department
over the years blackwell continued to
expand mathematics by introducing game
theory decision theory and information
theory into the field
let's suppose in particular that we knew
that all these xn's were greater than or
equal to a half
david blackwell
the first african-american elected to
the national academy of sciences
dedicated to assisting disadvantaged
students in the us and africa
first the advice i would give to
young people generally is
try everything
and keep looking until you find
something that you like
[Music]
since someone said what charisma that's
a perfect segue to introduce our next
speaker
[Applause]
thank you
um
can everyone hear me
so um i thought what i would do so even
though the title of my talk is uh
about the david blackwell's
approachability theorem
uh i would first say a little bit about
david blackwell
but more generally about the
about sort of the academic milieu in
which david blackwell was born into
i'll get to why i will do that in a
moment
and then i realized from talking
it said that
given my time i may not get to the
technical parts
but i hope you won't mind
so uh
i think one often reads the story of
david blackwell or interprets it as it's
the triumph of genius over racism
and while that's a possible
interpretation i want to describe sort
of the wider environment in which david
blackwell was born into
and in some sense come to a more
pessimistic conclusion which is it's
right time right place
and
so the picture that i chose for david
blackwell is
is one that appeared in
some of you may have seen this
many years ago time life
two
companies that no longer exist
but at one time were quite prominent
uh published a sequence of five volumes
devoted to the various sciences
with profiles of mathematicians and
scientists in them
one of the volumes is devoted to
mathematics and david blackwell is one
of the people that they profiled i think
this came out in the in the mid 60s and
this is the picture that they picked um
it's a younger david blackwell sitting
on a table there's chalk in his right
hand
uh because one of the things you will
notice if you read many of the oral
interviews of david blackwell he is
always jumping up and going to the board
to explain things okay
okay
so what was the environment into which
uh david blackwell entered so i have
here a list of the first 10 or so
phd's awarded to phd's in mathematics
awarded to african americans
i want to caution you that
you will find lists like this on
wikipedia and other places they should
be read with some care
some of them will amalgamate phd's and
mathematics with uh
with doctorates in the teaching of
mathematics so i have removed those from
this list and those lists are sometimes
incomplete there are some names that
don't appear
but over here i hope you can see albert
frank cox is the first
african-american to have received a phd
in mathematics
and uh i've cut off the list here
uh for a variety of reasons one running
out of space two running out of time and
uh three
uh after 1943 there is a change there
there is a change that's visible in
society and and i will get to that uh in
a moment
you will see here here is david
blackwell
and so what can we say about these
individuals well for example she's the
first african-american female to have
received a phd in mathematics
what was the profile of these uh
individuals mostly they were getting
phds for a combination of reasons
one they were primarily involved in
teaching and getting a phd was a way to
advance within the administrative ranks
what was special about these individuals
was that they chose phds in mathematics
rather than phds in education
so the typical profile would be get an
undergraduate degree perhaps staff in
high school then get a master's degree
wait a couple of years and then go on to
get a phd
an extreme version of this is uh
is wooded
wooded event was was a dean of arts and
sciences at howard university in his 40s
he decides to go back and get a phd
in mathematics from the university of
pennsylvania
studying um under the same
yep so
he decides to go back to get a phd in
mathematics from the university of
pennsylvania
returns to howard as a regular faculty
member
right so that's it
he gives up all other administrative uh
positions
okay so
so what's special then so what what
makes uh blackwell stand out in a
variety of ways well the most obvious is
that uh
david blackwell in this list is among
the first to go undergraduate masters
phd
with all of these others there are gaps
with one exception
william shiflin claytor
let me say a little something about
these others um
pierce is an interesting individual
he played football for the university of
atlanta
and his goal at the time was to be a
football coach
in his first appointment
he is asked can you teach mathematics
and he says yes so he's assigned to
teach mathematics and apparently
discovers a love for it
and eventually goes on to get a phd in
mathematics but stays primarily as an
educator
uh reuben roosevelt mcdaniel
um one of the things to keep in mind at
this stage at you know uh in
in this time period
is that schools for african americans
were different for schools for whites
for example uh in the south five months
of schooling was mandated for african
americans
six months for whites
and the required amount of schooling was
five versus i think seven years those
numbers keep changing as you move around
the south
son of a farmer
he has a falling out with his father
because he recommends to his father that
the father do crop rotation the father
thinks the son a bit arrogant there is a
fight the son is sent to live with his
aunt in washington dc
by this time he's finished his five
years of mandated schooling and he has a
job as a postman
one of the one of the places where he
delivers mail to is the office of the
navy
where he meets uh the future president
roosevelt
now the middle name does not come from
that there is some ambiguity about how
it's spelt on some documents the e is
mis this e is missing on other documents
it's present but roosevelt encourages
him to go on to high school at night
sorry during the day he finds a night
job for him
he eventually goes on to get a phd but
once again primarily the focus is
education okay
so three individuals that i now want to
talk about clata
blackwell and wilkins
okay
undergraduate phd
and then on to research okay
clayton
uh he comes to howard
gets an undergraduate and a master's
degree
goes on to get a phd
first job is at a small university in
virginia
where he is the mentor for kathleen
katherine
uh what is her name from hidden figures
i apologize
um
i just remember her first name kathleen
and i forgotten the last name uh because
uh
yes johnson sorry and johnson was the
was was uh was not her maiden name which
is why i'm which is why i'm confused
paper from his dissertation is published
in the annals of mathematics it's a
generalization of the kuratovsky theorem
to surfaces other than planes
his advisor john klein was also the
advisor of dudley woodard who was
plato's uh mentor at howard
uh klein writes that this is probably
the best thesis he's ever supervised
and attempts to get claytor into the
institute for advanced studies in
princeton
and now at that time the institute for
advanced studies was housed in the same
building as the mathematics department
at princeton the mathematics department
at princeton was firmly desegregated
and
clator was not
did not succeed in getting a fellowship
at the institute for that reason
he's struggling at this uh minor
institution in virginia to get research
done because of the teaching loads
so eventually uh his advisor wangle
something for him at michigan
initially unpaid
subsequently he wins a rosenwald
fellowship i'll explain why the
rosenwald fellowships are important in a
moment
which gives him funding for about a year
but uh it is clear from correspondence
at the time that the insecurity of his
position
is cutting in to his ability to do
serious mathematics
he ends up hanging around in michigan
for about two or three years unsuccess
without any kind of academic appointment
he has some kind of unofficial academic
appointment he is not permitted to
attend the seminars at the mathematics
department at the university of michigan
eventually the institute for advanced
studies gets its own building
they ask him to join them and at this
point he is completely frustrated and
writes back i have no intention of being
a guinea pig he joins the army world war
ii has started where he teaches
artillery and when the war finishes he
is hired at howard
where he spends the rest of his
professional career
primarily focused on
only focused on teaching
correspondence from his wife suggests
that
the frustration with racial barriers
completely turned him off from the
mathematical community okay
now we come to david harrell blackwell
so blackwell graduates from illinois he
also gets a rosenwald fellowship
the rosenwald fellowship was money from
the rosenwald foundation this is julius
rosenwald of sears robot fame
uh julian bond uh has pointed out that
in some sense
much of the african-american
intellectual aristocracy were funded at
the early stages with rosenwald money so
this is why so clato was identified as a
talented individual very early on
received the rosenwald funding but the
barriers
uh were for him too much
and so he ended up in some sense exiting
research mathematics okay
david blackwell also gets a rosenwald
fellowship the institute is now d is
desegregated he goes on to the institute
for advanced studies
and spends a year or two there
uh
i'm okay first job is at a university in
louisiana he's there for a year then to
clark university in atlanta for a year
and then howard university where he
spends about 10 to 12 years
so
openings in
openings and majority institutions are
typically not available to uh to
graduates at this time
if you look at where i cut off the dates
what you will notice is that you will
then start to see that some of the
individuals who receive phds their first
academic positions are at majority
institutions
rather than at primari primarily but
than uh hbcus historically black
colleges and universities
now uh another one i want to point out
is that we sometimes overlook is jesse
ernest wilkins
uh will so there's an interesting
difference between the two blackwell was
born in centralia illinois
to a relatively prosperous family
uh father was although as described as a
railroad worker was actually a manager
and mother was a school teacher
jesse ernst wilkins's father was a
cabinet member in the eisenhower
administration
and received his phd from the university
of chicago at the age of 19.
he also received the rosenwald
fellowship and went to the institute for
advanced studies
only job he got
was at the tuskegee institute again he
started an hbcu
he went there a year and then afterwards
was
was asked by vigner to join him in the
manhattan project right
wilkins went
eventually left academic mathematics for
a while why is that
he had a far more promising career as a
nuclear engineer
he went on to earn two degrees in
engineering from new york university
and was a prime example of the
technocrat that arose from the end of
world war ii he had an expertise in
nuclear power
and uh he ended up becoming the second
african-american to be inducted to the
national academy of engineering okay
what is interesting is that blackwell
and wilkins met only once when blackwell
was head of the mathematics department
at howard he attempted to hire wilkins
uh wilkins came for the interview at
that time he was what we would now call
a chief technology officer at the uh the
american optical company
and instead of accepting the offer
wilkins in fact recruits one of the
junior faculty members that blackwell
has just hired uh
whose name often is missing from these
lists of phd's and african of african
americans who've received phds in
mathematics hires him into the american
optical company um
and uh
um so that was their only contact many
years later after wilkins had retired
basically from industry and government
work
he returned to howard as head of the
department and set up their phd program
okay
so what i want to sort of this is why
now why do i want to say this is a story
about right time right place
just look at these three individuals so
both of them all three of them showed
great promise early on
uh except uh the outcome for clata was
dramatically different okay
now what was interesting i think about
these two not just the fact that the
institute was desegregated
it is also that these two were involved
in areas that were soon to become big
for wilkins it was nuclear power nuclear
energy
what about david blackwell
well david blackwell was in washington
d.c
he himself describes the mathematical
atmosphere at howard as moribund
probably not his word but my
interpretation of his description so how
did he continue to be mathematically
active
and the reason is is because
at towards the tail end of world war ii
many mathematicians were going to
washington to consult arrow
gershik was
was the chief statistician at the
department of agriculture
dancing was coming regularly
and david blackwell
was working with them so this would be
the early days of an area that we might
now call the mathematics of decision
making
david blackwell was there at the start
in fact he had met some of these people
much earlier in his career when he was
at the institute for advanced studies
and in fact even earlier when he was an
undergraduate at illinois one of his
contemporaries was abraham chance one of
the early pioneers of linear program
okay so this is what i mean by right
time right place those connections
enabled him to get to spend the summers
at the rand institute in california and
so this is why my interpretation is
it's less about genius triumphing over
racism because i look at the fate of
william clayton and more about
right time right place right yeah maybe
the power of collaboration
say again
it's the power of right so it's a number
of things coming together and in the
oral interviews of david blackwell he he
is always very careful to emphasize that
it's the it's he learns a lot from other
people
we all do right and so so so david
blackwell in some sense was lucky enough
to benefit from that and uh and
you know william plato not
okay
uh
hey so
that's sort of the background
later today you will hear sort of more
personal reflections on david blackwell
but i think providing some background of
the general sort of
general milieu is useful okay
okay
now uh
based on the interviews that i've read
uh
these are
blackwell's three favorite papers
this offers an alternative theory of
probability as a as a competitor to the
kolmogorov
uh interpretation
blackwell himself complains that nobody
has really taken this up all right
here's the second and you'll notice i
have three papers
they're all related to approachability
the reason why i put them together is
the following
uh
this
is essentially a lemma
that is used here
this
i think is what motivated david
blackwell
to produce this
so this if you like is the first
published application of approachability
blackwell would call this the vector
minimax theorem okay which is why i
bundle these three together
third favorite paper is the one on
merging of opinions
so
let me tell you very quickly what this
is about
i have a prior distribution over some
state space
you have a prior distribution over the
same state space
then things are drawn from the state
space we update our priors a la bayes
is it the case that our posteriors will
converge because we are looking at the
same information
okay the blackwell double dubin's
theorem says as long as my prior is
absolutely continuous with respect to
yours in other words we don't disagree
in the following sense you assign
measure zero to something that i
assigned positive measure to okay we
will eventually converge and that notion
of convergence is called merging okay
uh
okay now
the reason why i mention this will come
in we will come a little later on in the
talk i'd like to talk about the
approachability theorem and uh tell you
a little bit about its connections to
sort of more current research that many
of you will be familiar with yes is that
kind of like the helmet here
uh so the outline theorem is about um
no so in the almond theorem it is you
and me exchanging information right so
here there is no information exchange it
is simply we are observing draw draws
from the same urn
related to the specified part
uh
no no so so so the uh no it's the the
so we've misspecified um
okay so with misspecified priors your
it's that you don't have the correct
prior distribution in this case both of
us uh
there is uh there is no statement about
that it
we simply have two different priors and
the only question is under what
conditions would we eventually agree on
on the distribution of the state space
and the condition is that look there has
to be some kind of agreement in our
priors to begin with which is this
absolutely absolute continuity condition
okay
let me describe now the approachability
theorem and i'm going to describe it
without any interpretation in terms of
games i want to describe it simply as
some property of sequences
and uh so here is one version i'm going
to give you a sequence of vectors from a
bounded set
i'm going to keep track of the average
of the vectors
every new vector in the sequence that i
picked must have this property
now if you think of these vectors as
being numbers
then notice what this condition is
saying
if the current average is positive
the new number that i give you must be
negative
if the current averages is negative the
new number i give you must be positive
in other words the new number that i
give you
must be on the other side
where the origin represents the dividing
lines of the average
what's the conclusion
that the average has to converge to zero
now i think if you look if you think
about numbers you say yeah that has to
be true okay and so here i've replaced
number by vector
and this of course must be dot product
so therefore yeah it's the other side in
let's generalize a little bit
i will give you a sequence of bounded
vectors
i will give you a convex set t
again i keep track of the average
and now i want to keep track of the
closest point on the convex set to the
average
my new vector
xn plus one
okay so
let's see let me draw a picture here
here is t
here is the average
that's this pi t of a n
and then what is this condition saying
it's saying that my new vector must be
on opposite this opposite means what it
must be
something like this on the other side of
this tangent hyperplane
if this is always true
then eventually my averages have to
converge to something in the set
again if you think about it yeah that
just seems absolutely has to be right
next variation
everything as before
except now
it's before this dot product was
deterministically negative
i've added expectation
okay
so now all i'm telling you is that this
new vector
is generated from some distribution
the only property of the distribution
is that the expectation of this dot
product is less than or equal to zero
now you say to yourself
that's the only difference
if these x ends are iid
then of course the pr this conclusion
has to be true
whereas the subtlety
i've not said that these have to be id
so the remarkable feature is i only need
that expectation to hold i don't need
these accents to be
independent draws
now how do you get this you get this
using
in blackwell's paper from the lemma here
from this lemma here
which is essentially a version of
semi-martingale convergence right so you
need something stronger than the
standard law of large numbers okay
okay
so this is the approachability theorem
purely mathematically no interpretation
whatsoever yes great question are the
expectations not even conditioned in the
past
not even condition of the past oh it's
just
just the expectation of that incident
okay
so here is the interpretation that
blackwell provides and this is why he
calls it a generalization of von
neumann's mini-max theorem
i have a two player game and again my
two players are called row and column
they repeatedly choose a strategy so
column chooses a column row chooses a
row but the outcome of the game is not a
single number as it is in the standard
uh zero-sum game setup the outcome of
the game is a vector
okay what i keep track of is the average
vector produced
there is a target set which is convex
what makes this a game is
i want to know if r
has a strategy
that forces the average towards the
target set
and the approachability theorem
basically says a convex set t is
approachable if and only if every
tangent hyperplane of the target set is
approachable
so mathematically it boils down to do i
have a mixed strategy at every stage
that guarantees this condition
if i do then i just invoke this result
so applying the theorem means simply
making sure you can do this at each
stage
okay
okay
now
the theorem has been generalized in
every way i think you can imagine and so
just for your edification i think i've
captured every possible thing that you
could play with
blackwell's version has finite actions
for column and row
you can generalize that to compact
action spaces
approachability is in terms of the
euclidean distance between the average
and the target set you can replace it
with other norms
blackwell was looking at the simple
average of the outcomes
you can do various kinds of weighted
averages
blackwell had finite dimensional vectors
infinite dimensions
you can relax convex target set to a
closed target set
blackwell was relying on randomization
you can then ask how well can you do if
you restrict yourselves to deterministic
strategies
in blackwell both sides can observe
everything they see the whole game
you can relax that to some kind of
partial observability and if there's any
variation i've ignored please tell me
right now
i missed on the row column player what
were the actions of the room uh so uh
row is simply choosing a row of a matrix
and column is choose sorry and column is
choosing a column of the matrix but each
entry of the matrix is a vector
like what's it relate to in this picture
okay so the
so so in this picture when i choose a
row you choose a column the outcome is a
vector
and we do this each period
and then we look at the average of the
of the outcomes which would be the
average of the vectors the average of
those vectors is this
uh oh i just realized one other
fine it's discrete time
there's a generalization to continuous
time
okay now uh
why on earth is this theorem useful and
this is where i'm going to explain the
little snippet that you showed from
blackwell um
[Music]
so
it turned out that a year after
blackwell published his vector minimax
theorem
james hanan published his paper on bayes
minimax regret okay
the hanan paper is uh proves a theorem
that has been proved many many times
afterwards in different areas
so in computer science it's known as the
experts theorem in information theory
it's called universal compression
uh
in game so uh and in game theory there's
a connection with fictitious play and
learning in zero-sum games
and uh
blackwell pointed out that hanan's
theorem was a special case of his vector
minimax theorem
and he wrote up a little note
showing how you would do the argument
uh
i have only seen a version of it from
around the early 2000s so this cannot
have been the original note
but if you look in the appendix of luce
and rafa's book games and decisions they
actually describe the hanan theorem and
they point out that it's a consequence
of the approachability theorem of david
blackwell and so i simply want to show
you how you would use it in this context
and then you will see why
approachability is useful
so i'm going to ask you to predict the
next element of an infinite sequence of
zeros and ones
and i'm going to measure your
performance by the fraction of incorrect
guesses after n periods
and so i want to keep track of this
which is the fraction of ones h n
one minus h n is the fraction of zeros
and what blackwell is going to convince
you of is that i have that we have a
strategy
with the following property if you
follow it the fraction of incorrect
guesses
is smaller than
the fraction of incorrect guesses
if you predict one all the time or you
predict zero all the time
plus an error term that's going to zero
as n goes to infinity
in the context of the language of
experts you have two experts one expert
i know it seems an exaggeration only
predicts one
and the other expert only predicts zero
and this says that by combining their
predictions in some sense you can do
better than both of them
okay
so
how do you do this well here is the idea
l02 is going to be the error at time t
if you predict zero
l one t is the error at time t if you
predict one so i'm keeping track of your
mistakes from predicting one and your
mistakes from predicting zero
now the outcome from predicting zero at
time t is going to be represented as a
vector
the vector has two components
and the outcome from predicting one at
time t is going to be represented by
this vector
so here is the game
i'm row i can choose 0 or 1
your column you can choose 0 or 1.
what's the payoff the payoff is not a
number it's a vector
now
uh
l0 is the error from predicting zero
l superscript one is the error
from predicting one
and maybe not
the first coordinate zero let's say this
in the last line the first formula
uh oh you're asking what's the
interpretation so the answer is i simply
want to rep so rather than present
aggregate error i want to separate out
the nature of the errors into two
components that's it okay
now
so now what blackwell is going to ask is
let the target set be the negative
author
can i push the average of these over a
number of rounds into the negative order
now notice if i succeed
then that would mean
that both of these components must be
the average of them over time must be
less than or equal to zero
in other words i must be doing better
than
predicting all ones
or predicting all zeros
so
let wt be the probability of predicting
zero at time t
what would the average of those vectors
be it would be this
right so
this counts up the mistakes when you
predict zero
and predict one so the way to think
about this is this is the regret you
would feel so you predicted zero and
then you asked gosh what if i had
predicted one instead
target set is the non-positive orphan
and now it's enough to check whether the
negative authentic is approachable so
you just check that hyperplane condition
and if it is you're done i'll skip the
algebra because if you can approach the
negative authentic you're done the
existence of such a scheme is given
not only do you have existence the proof
itself gives you an algorithm
okay so this is the basic way in which
the approachability theorem is used you
look at your online decision problem you
reformulate it as a vector zero sum game
you identify an appropriate target set
and then you check a hyper plane
condition to see if you can approach any
tangent hyperplane to your target set
now does this give you the best possible
algorithm in all circumstances not
necessarily
but it's an off-the-shelf algorithm to
get what you want to get
okay
now um
so hanan i think called this property no
regret or people afterwards have called
this no regret
there and uh in a in an early paper
foster dean foster and i gave this a
formal name no external regret in the
sense that here is hamann's theorem
which is this is your loss from choosing
action i at time n so you can have more
than two actions the losses don't have
to be zero one any bounded number will
do
and there exists a randomized rule so
that your average loss is less than the
smallest average loss from your best
strategy in hindsight
[Music]
there is another notion called internal
regret
um
which
which goes roughly like this i look at
all the times that i played action i
and i asked what if i had played action
j instead and i do that for all possible
pairs and i want all of those
differences to be going to zero meaning
i don't want any regret any sort of lack
of consistency in the choice of my
actions
in at when uh dean foster and i proved
this it was stronger than standard no
regret
i'll get to the rest of the story i hope
in time and you can prove again using
david blackwell's approachability
theorem that such no internal regret
strategies exist
right okay so the picture you should
have in mind is approachability implies
hanan no regret approachability implies
no internal regret no internal regret
implies hanan's no regret
okay
all of this from approachability
and now let me tie this back to merging
with uh something that seems at first
glance very different
instead of choosing actions i'm going to
ask you to make probability forecasts of
a binary event
so you're looking at an infinite
sequence i want you to tell me the
probability of the next entry in the
sequence being a one
you're free to announce different ps in
different periods how should i measure
the accuracy of your forecast
now of course the problem here is if i
say there's a 50 chance of rain and it
rains that's not a mistake
okay so here is one way that you might
think about measuring the accuracy of my
forecast
look at the average of all of my
forecasts and compare that with the
average of the ones if those are close
together then presumably i'm telling you
something informative
a little reflection will show weight
that's a little fishy
here is a potential outcome
here are forecasts
by this measure i'm looking good
but of course i seem to have missed
the trees for the forest
so you can say
we understand what's going on here
you know looking at the aggregate
sequence that's losing information
why don't we be a little more refined
why don't we break up the sequence into
two subsequences for example even
periods and odd periods and then impose
the same requirement on the even periods
as you do on the odd periods
now here's another example that says
wait even that's going to be fishy
i simply predict 0.5 but again i seem to
be missing completely the pattern in the
data
so then you might say oh wait we know
what to do now you'd like to break up
the data into different subsequences
uh so let's go let's do the breaking up
via an algorithm the algorithm is called
the checking rule
so how can i break up the subsequence
well the decision to include any period
in a subsequence we can allow it to
depend on the history of the outcomes
and the forecast to date
so
you give me a collection of checking
rules basically a collection of
subsequences
my goal is to make probability
predictions so that on each subsequence
the average of my forecasts is equal to
the average of the ones okay
so to pass a checking rule means that on
the relevant subsequences the average of
your ps should be close to the average
of your once
a very particular case of this is called
naive calibration where the checking
rule is as follows i look at alls i look
at all subsequences where you announce
let's say a ten percent chance of seeing
a one
the fraction of one should be ten
percent i look at all subsequences where
you announced a twenty three percent
chance of seeing a one the fraction of
ones should be 23
so this is the condition i would want to
hold for all possible choices of p
that have that are announced
sufficiently frequently why well if you
announced a probability 0.27 only once
nothing really i can do with that
okay well
given a checking rule is there a
forecasting algorithm that will pass it
for all possible realizations of the
data via blackwell approachability the
answer is yes
given a finite collection of checking
rules is there a forecasting procedure
that will pass all of the checking rules
simultaneously
by blackwell's approachability theorem
yes
what about any countable collection
in other words any turing-computable
algorithm
for producing checking rules
by the appropriate generalization of the
approachability theorem the answer is
yes
okay now before you get too excited and
think wait we've solved the problem of
forecasting
there's a negative interpretation of
this which i'll get to in a moment what
about all checking rules
this it turns out is related to
blackwell's third favorite paper merging
which is if you had a forecasting
procedure that passed all possible
checking rules
whatever probability distribution that
you are announcing must merge in the
sense of blackwell and do bins with the
true underlying probability distribution
and uh so what this analysis highlights
is the importance of how you measure
accuracy
calibration the way i described it is a
backward guarantee meaning i go into the
future
i look back and i tell you i look good
merging
is a forward guarantee merging says i go
into the future at some point beyond
that point i'm going to guarantee you
that you're going to look good much
stronger requirement but much more
demanding to meet
okay i am almost at the end of my time
here so
approachability implies hanan no regret
implies no internal regret implies
calibration
in the last couple of years people have
closed the loop you can start with
calibration any algorithm that passes
any collection of any countable
collection of checking rules can be an
algorithm that can be used to prove
blackwell's approachability theorem and
can be used to prove no internal regret
can be used to prove no regret so the
circle now is completely closed in some
sense all of these mathematically are
the same object okay but they have very
different interpretations so blackwell
was originally interested in
generalizing the minimax theorem
and when we get to this particular way
of thinking about things it's a question
about how can i tell whether you indeed
know something
and this is the negative interpretation
i know nothing at all about the weather
but i can make probability predictions
that will look very reasonable
this should make you suspicious all
right
okay and i think let me end here unless
there are questions
[Applause]
go ahead
my checking will be all
subsequences
like
any countable collection
so the checking rule can be a function
of the history of the outcomes and the
history of the forecasts
and that's obtained from a
generalization of the approachability
here into infinite dimensions
can you just quickly get the reference
for the closing the loop ah okay so the
closing the loop is the result of uh
independent work like the critical
rituals but if you are looking for a
nice survey of all of these together
there is a survey paper by diane perche
p-e-r-c-h-e-t or you can send me an
email i think it appeared in the journal
of
dynamics and control in 2014
i think
and
it
has all the proofs
and has all the formal statements of all
of the results and so
one stop shopping
okay well thanks very much
he would not want
okay uh let's see
if i don't care
yes
just
she's
yes
thank you very much for attending the
talk i think and thank you robert for
giving